مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
نفاع كان في حديث خلال كاس عالم للانديه
اللي صار او اللي عم يصير بالسعوديه حاليا
عن موضوع عدم نجاح الانديه السعوديه
بالوصول لنهائي البطوله وخصوصا بعد خروج
نادي الاتحاد وكانت وجهه نظر جماهير
الهلال انه الهلال هو الفريق الوحيد
القادر على انه يوصل لنهائي كاس عالم
للانديه والدليل كاس عالم للانديه الماضي
اللي لعب فيه الهلال امام ريال مدريد
بالنهائي هل هذا الكلام دقيق ولا لا هذا
اللي جايين نناقشه اليوم بكل امانه الهلال
هو الفريق الاكثر خبرا بالسعوديه على
المستوى القاري والدولي والسبب في ذلك انه
الهلال عنده تجارب سابقه عنده بطولات
كبيره لعبها عنده محافل قاريه كبيره لاعب
في فيها لعب نهائي دوري ابطال اسيا كثير
مؤخرا باخر تقريبا 10 15 سنه كان هو ممثل
السعوديه بدوري ابطال اسيا لا بل انه
بمرحله من المراحل كان قريب من انه يسيطر
على القاره لسنوات متتاليه لو ما انه خسر
النهائي لذلك الهلال اكثر خبره بالتاكيد
الهلال مش بس اكثر خبره هو اكثر استقرارا
على المستوى الاداري استقرار الهلال على
المستوى الاداري بيعطيه دفعه دائما الى
الامام بيعطيه حاله من وجود رؤيه او
استراتيجيه على المدى البعيد سنوات وسنوات
بخطط وها بفكروا فيها وبيمشوا باتجاه
هدفهم ما بيضيعوا البوصله ابدا بالطريق
نحو الهدف وهذا امر بيساعد الفريق كثير
بعالم كره القدم انه يكون ناجح اطلع على
اوروبا اليوم عندك ريال مدريد فريق مستقر
اداريا عندك بايرن ميونخ فريق مستقر
اداريا عندك السيتي فريق مستقر اداريا وهي
الانديه هي تقريبا انجح ثلاث انديه
باوروبا باخر ع سنوات وهذا بدل على انه
الاستقرار الاداري عامل مهم جدا بالنسبه
لاي فريق فالهلال وجود الاستقرار الاداري
عنده بميزه عن بقيه الفرق السعوديه النقطه
الاخرى المهمه جدا جوده اللاعبين اللي عند
الهلال كانت حتى قبل موضوع صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه والصفقات وما الى ذلك
الهلال كان عنده خيره اللاعبين السعوديين
وكان اي لاعب يتالق باي نادي اخر
بالسعوديه يشتري الهلال ونشوفه عم يلعب
بصفوفه طبعا باستثناء النصر و
كنا نشوف اسماء كبيره مثل سلمان الفرج
سالم الدوسري كنو والقائمه تطول لذلك
الهلال منذ زمن طويل وهو زعيم الكره
السعوديه محليا اضف الى ذلك انه عنده خبره
بالمحافل الدوليه وشخصيا شفت انجح وافضل
مباراه لانديه عربيه ضد انديه كبيره
باوروبا بالنسبه لي كانت مباراه الهلال
وتشيلسي بكاس عالم للانديه 2021 واللي
حضرتها من الملعب باستاد محمد بن زايد في
ابو ظبي وكانت تلك المباراه فعلا واحده من
اجمل المباريات اللي قدمتها الفرق العربيه
امام الفرق الاوروبيه لكبيره لحتى اجت
بعدها طبعا مباراه السعوديه والارجنتين
وغيرت النظره وصارت هي رقم واحد ولكن هل
كل ما ذكر يعني انه بقيه الانديه السعوديه
غير قادره على الوصول للنهائي وغير قادره
على تحقيق الانجاز بصراحه شخصيا كنت متوقع
بهي النسخه من كاس العالم للانديه انه
الاتحاد يذهب بعيدا فيها ويوصل ل النهائي
وليش لا ينافس على اللقب لانه الاتحاد
عنده المقومات عنده النجوم عنده الاسماء
عنده يفترض انه المنظومه ولكن اللي
اكتشفناه بمباراه الاهلي المصري والاتحاد
انه الاتحاد افتقد للمنظومه وكان عنده
اسماء ولاعبين وما الى ذلك ولكن المنظومه
ما كانت موجوده فكانت المباراه منظومه بلا
نجوم ضد نجوم بلا منظومه ونجح الاهلي
بالوصول لنصف النهائي وبنعرف طبعا انه خسر
لاحقا من فلومينينسي
البرازيلي ال الان انديه السعوديه لحتى
تحقق نجاحات عالميه والعربيه عامه مش بس
السعوديه العربيه عامه هي بحاجه لاولا
استقرار اداري لمدرب يطول لانه عندنا
مشكله ببعض الدول العربيه انه كل ما ساءت
النتائج اقيل المدرب يعني ما في صبر على
المدرب ما في تجيب مدرب تعطيه مشروع وتصبر
عليه مثلا خمس سنوات ست سنوات مثل مثلا ما
عم نشوف ارتيتا مع ارسنال مثل ما عم نشوف
اليوم تشافي مع برشلونه وقبل الكثير من
الاس والمدربين فلذلك محتاج مشروع مستقر
فنيا واداريا يوصلك لمرحله معينه من
الاستقرار وتذهب بعيدا بالبطولات القاريه
والعالميه النصر بعد ما شفناه النصر يمكن
اذا شارك بكاس العالم للانديه يقدم
مستويات ممتازه جدا لانه النصر وجهه نظر
النصر يقدم امتع كره قدم في السعوديه
حاليا نعم الهلال اقوى بلا شك الهلال
الاقوى بلا شك ولكن النصر كمت ك بناء لعب
كتدوي كره كتنظيم صفوف انا من وجهه نظري
هو كان افضل فريق سعودي هذا الموسم من
ناحيه المتعه والاداء داخل ارضيه الملعب
كمان الاهلي قد يعود الى مستوه الطبيعي
ويكون قادر على تحقيق ايضا الانجازات
العالميه والقاريه ولكن لحد ه اللحظه نحن
شايفين انه الفريق السعودي الوحيد اللي
وصل لنهائي كاس عالم الانديه هو الهلال
وهذا الشيء له اسبابه اللي ذكرت هذا كان
كل شيء بحلقه الوم بعد الصافره حتى نلتق
الاسبوع المقبل كونوا بالف
خير